Matt Bomer weighs in on those infamous  feud rumors between Channing Tatum and  Alex Pettyfer there was never any  undercurrent of tension that I witnessed  for years rumors have swirled that  Channing and Alex didn't get along on  the set of Magic Mike  the 27 year olds even told The Hollywood  Reporter in 2015 quote Channing does not  like me that's weird  so when their co-star stopped by watch  what happens live with Andy Cohen on  Thursday he was asked about the alleged  beef on set in the first film everybody  was really professional Channing is one  of the most fun people I've ever worked  with he said a great tone and and Matt  didn't stop there they both came to work  on time did great work and there was  never any undercurrent of tension that I  witnessed the 39 year olds added that he  may have missed any onset tension  because he was too focused on what he  was wearing or rather what he wasn't  wearing  [Applause]  you